[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
charlie kirk
does not want to be called a fascist
maybe stop being a goddamn fascist and
you won't be called a fascist charlie
kirk
no this small face having son of a [ __ ]
i don't i have no idea exactly how we're
gonna get uh
through today without uh mentioning that
charlie kirk had a turning point usa
event a student event down in florida
and there were nazis outside there were
there were actual nazis
that like the actual thing they were
carrying flags they had the uniforms on
they were proud to be nazis charlie
that's why we get to call you a fascist
that's why
not not because we like the word fascist
really honestly i wish there weren't
fascists in this country it would be a
much easier much easier time if we
didn't have fascists like you running
around trying to take people's rights
away from them
you [ __ ] bigot
you're racist you're a bigot
you're you're a [ __ ] fascist you're a
nazi charlie kirk is a nazi
so
he gets really butthurt that joe biden
called them semi-fascists like come on
man semi-fascist give me a [ __ ] break
semi-fascist that's what you're upset
about
charlie
come on man get with the game here
you're not upset because someone called
you a semi-fascist you're upset that
someone called you a fascist and it's
the truth
and people are on to you that's what
you're pissed off about
that nazis are showing up at your events
because they love you
they love you charlie the nazis love you
charlie they love you
but it is really something else to watch
shirley charlie kirk be mad about words
be mad about being called names as if
he's never called a liberal or a
democrat a socialist than a cabinet
a baby killer baby murderer
come on charlie
come on
quit being such a [ __ ]
stop being such a [ __ ] wimp
stop
just get on with it if you really want
to you know
select your fear her which is donald
trump and continue this fascist state or
maybe it's ron desantis i don't know i
don't know if you've moved on from trump
or not
now that it looks like trump is uh
inevitably gonna get indicted
i mean it
how have you been watching
fraud social over there holy actual [ __ ]
grandpa
has got to be running out of diapers i
mean it is just
over there on fraud social
there he is just losing
his [ __ ] mind and really you know
some people would say a guy like that
has lost his marbles i actually don't
think he lost his marbles i think the
marbles packed their [ __ ] and they
[ __ ] left like this guy's nuts i
can't handle this fred i can't do this
anymore pack your [ __ ] let's get the
hell out of here the marbles are gone
they [ __ ] left they didn't they they
didn't want anything to do with this guy
that's how crazy it is over there fraud
social
and grandpa poopy pants his cell phone
he has lost his mind he's he's
re-truthing all kinds of crazy-ass [ __ ]
of course
q and honors neo-nazis of course this is
where we're going with this
uh he's spreading lies about an fbi
agent or some [ __ ] i don't know what the
hell he's talking about
he he's posted it a few times something
about an fbi agent getting fired
there's and and i don't i don't know if
he read this on a q a on post board or
somewhere on like 8chan or 4chan or some
[ __ ] i don't know
but this guy has lost his god damn mind
we find out last night also
that he's been spreading
rumors
about intel
that he has on presidents and other
countries this is why it is going to be
so important for the department of
justice to act here
it is super important for the department
of justice to act and i i believe that's
like he's forcing them to
like it would be a situation if he would
have cooperate actually cooperated not
like trump type cooperation where he say
he's doing something and he's doing the
opposite but if he actually would have
cooperated in getting these documents
back
his team would have worked and focused
on making sure to follow laws and
get these documents back where they
belong to the government
then he wouldn't have such a problem
here but he's created a lot of problems
on his own which donald trump does
but honestly this is of his prosecution
here for these top secret documents and
how he's mishandled them and possibly
breaking the espionage act the
presidential records act
um maybe even treason i mean i don't
know i don't know what he's sold or what
he's traded i have no idea at this point
he's obviously willing to brag about the
[ __ ] that he has in these boxes that are
supposed to be classified and top secret
and maybe that's the other reason why
cash patel his little lap dog is
continuing to say no he has the
unilateral authority to declassify these
documents which is not [ __ ] true
i mean a president of the united states
an actual sitting president the person
who holds the office has the power to
declassify stuff that is true
but you don't just wave your hands and
you know take a bite of your [ __ ] big
mac and
i don't know declare diet coke the king
and make these documents declassified
that's not how it [ __ ] works
and it definitely doesn't work after
you've stole them and taken them to your
golf course and stuffed them in your
wife's underwear drawer and then
declassify them then
that's not something that happens the
other thing too is this ndi information
it doesn't matter the classification the
ndi information you can't you can't
compromise that information that's
that's national defense information
and that that goes into also breaking
laws so
the guy is freaking out absolutely
freaking the [ __ ] out on fraud social he
can't stop himself but to crime
this morning
more january 6 news breaks in where john
eastman is not going to get his [ __ ]
cell phone back
the federal courts have said no you're
not going to get your [ __ ] cell phone
back
so now he not only has criminal
liability that he has to worry about
with the select committee and doj
turning up stuff for the january 6
insurrection where he tried to overthrow
our vote
speaking of that in georgia the same
goddamn thing the state of georgia is
investigating his ass for trying to
overturn an election and commit and
commit election tampering but now the
guy just can't help himself
but to put himself in a position where
he forces the department of justice
forces them
to prosecute him on these top secret
documents because i think that's
exactly what the department of justice
has done nara didn't want this i i
actually believe that no one actually
wanted to go down this road with these
documents with this fool like they would
much rather have this out in a court
about january 6 about overturning
elections
about that kind of stuff they would they
would much rather have that fight but he
is forcing them to have this prosecution
in this fight in courts about these
documents and the crimes that he's
committed after he was president which
is also very important here
i think a lot of people are missing that
but this guy did this [ __ ] after he was
president this isn't while he's
president this is after he's the
president of the united states
it really is something else to see and
we have really reached the point in our
history that we've never seen and we'll
probably never see again
where a president united states is an
absolute criminal
he absolutely stole these documents from
the united states government us they're
our documents
and he was going to use him for
nefarious reasons and yet you can't
believe anything else but that because
it is [ __ ] trump
and he's bragging about how he's got
information about mccrone sex life to
people at the golf course i don't know
if he's sanded into the microphone when
he's crashing these weddings or what
but this [ __ ] guy is just off the
chain
off the chain and really honestly i know
the department of justice is trying to
wait you know they're watching their
their clock to see how long it's going
to take to get this election over with
but man this thing is getting really
[ __ ] really [ __ ] crazy
really crazy really quick now we have
joe biden the president of the united
states he's going to give a uh some kind
of statement or or speech or something
um on the state of
of our union and giving the
rundown of why why our rights and
liberty at risk if you don't pay
attention uh apparently that is going to
be thursday i believe thursday and prime
time i think we're going to actually
stream that live
and we'll probably stream it on the
midas touch network so be paying
attention to
the links the minus touch network um
over on the midas touch network's
youtube channel because i think we're
gonna be streaming that that speech or
that event or
whatever whatever it ends up being we'll
take a look at that this morning
and figure out what that is we have
texas paul with us today texas paul is
going to come in you know it's tuesday
it's taco tuesday and it's texas paul
tuesday texas paul has some beto news
that he'd like to uh uh have a
discussion about and i'm sure we're
going to talk about um charlie kirk
being butthurt about the word fascist
jupiter called us a fascist
poor charlie kirk [ __ ] him
[ __ ] charlie kirk now here's the other
thing is there's a lot of video to get
to today and i i think we'll review some
of it with texas paul and then we'll do
the shitless round up in the second hour
so here's how it's going to work we're
going to go for another
15 min 10 or 15 minutes i'm going to
yell and scream into the microphone then
we're going to bring texas paulin at the
bottom of the hour and at the top of the
other we'll go to the [ __ ] list roundup
now welcome to all the new listeners
here on the tony michaels podcast you
know we broadcast every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
and twitch so do not forget to hit that
subscribe button
don't forget to hit the subscribe button
you're not gonna want to miss a thing
not gonna miss a thing also go follow us
on twitter at tonymichaelspod
where you can vote this week for bow net
of the week we do bone of the week every
single friday big news
we are going to be airing bonet of the
week on friday friday evening on the
midas touch network so please go over
there and follow a minus touch network
you'll see bonehead of the week so we'll
do it live we do it live during the tony
michaels podcast in the second hour on
friday where you vote you decide who is
the bonehead of the week and then we air
re-air the bonehead of the week on the
midas touch network every single friday
night you can also download every single
episode on apple spotify and google
while you're there downloading every
single episode don't forget to subscribe
and leave us a great review on the
directory of your choice
because we're on all those directories
i think all of them i don't know how
many there are there's probably a ton of
them
there's gotta be just a shitload of them
just a shitload of them we've got a ton
of news today and it's rolling in and
there's a lot of trending topics um that
we want to talk about of course i want
to go through this charlie kirk video
where he's crying about
about joe biden calling him a
semi-fascist which again i think jill
biden's being very nice to him the other
thing too is there's a lot of jill rogan
video out there joe rogan apparently had
a aaron rodgers on his show oh my god
these two idiots talking about politics
oh my god well how how could we not pay
attention to that how could anyone not
want to listen to aaron rodgers and joe
rogan hear what commentary they have on
politics those two dumb [ __ ] oh
my god i'm sure it's just it's just a
riveting of course they say some really
stupid [ __ ] some false information
misinformation because they're [ __ ]
so we're going to run through that i'm
also ronnie jackson is trending this
morning i'm not real real sure right
it's probably because he's a traitor uh
they're having another cpac maybe
because this trending and culture
is trending which we'll probably run
through why that is
um
but we're gonna get to uh texas paul
here in just a minute here in just a
minute
everyone uh stick around we'll bring
texas paul in right after this break
stick around don't go anywhere we'll be
right back
right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
[Music]
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this
is that moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast
welcome to all the new listeners out
there
we broadcast every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter and
twitch
simulcast from the midas touch facebook
page
the midas touch facebook page we have
one of the minus mighty favorites here
today with us texas paul
with his reacts he's he sent me
something this morning um a tweet from
beto o'rourke you know texas balls in
texas and he's down there trying to help
out beto well he's trying to help all
around the country he's been putting out
videos giving you an idea of exactly
what you can do to engage in your
democracy because you know here at the
tony michaels podcast we lean into
democracy we do not shy away from it we
will politicize every single goddamn
issue if we have to to save our
democracy i am not scared of that i am
not scared of what they call me like
charlie kirk is scared to be called a
fascist oh
poor guy
poor feller oh man he's so weak
we have someone who is not weak who is
who is just like me who loves who loves
to lean into democracy texas paul
welcome on tuesday texas paul how are
you
i'm wonderful man you got to forgive me
i sound a little bit like bullfrog today
had a little bit of a uh
covert rebound but i'm doing good oh i'm
doing is that is that from the um the
the uh
the drug the same thing that biden had
is that is that is that what that is
just like the the second wave of it kind
of thing
yeah apparently this b85 is pretty big
on doing rebounds whether you use the
pax love it or not you
you're you get over it and then it's
like your immune system has vietnam
flashbacks
oh i see that
i see so so it gives you just an extra
kick in the ass a few days later is that
what you're saying exactly
i got you well you sent me a tweet this
morning about uh the beto and what's
going on down there and he he's really
he's really hammering through the state
and i i i heard that uh he had he had
gotten sick and everyone was lying about
oh he's suspended his campaign and he's
quitting and he's dying or something i
don't know some [ __ ] of course they're
gonna lie
everything that that went through the
right wing blind sphere like crazy
immediately the guy got a bacterial
infection i mean you can't do that many
public appearances without getting sick
i mean he got covered a few months back
and i mean
the guy literally if you've never been
to one of these town halls it's amazing
the amount of time that he puts into
these things he will literally if the
entire town hall stands up and says i
want a picture he will stay for the
whole thing and he puts his arm around
him he shakes their hands and you you
just can't come into contact with tens
of thousands of people and not catch a
buck every once in a while and that's
what happened here he got a bacterial
infection and uh you know he's been
burning the candle at both ends so he
got a little got a little sick he went
to the hospital they gave him uh an iv
um
he went home to rest for a few days and
then the right wing blogs for
apparently he was
dying and his campaign was suspended and
everything no the campaign's running
running full bore
he just had it he's trying to take a
break back on the road well you know
even even with him being sick he's still
kicking gray gab's ass down there i mean
that's that's the craziest part you know
he he's he's running sick running sick
but he he can kick grades greg abbott's
ass um every which way
loose here and and i think i think
that's the the thing that betto has done
so well and i think it's a model for all
democrats everywhere now let me pull
this uh tweet up that you sent here let
me see if i can find it you sent it to
me this morning and he was trying to
point out exactly what was going on in
the state of texas uh i think that's
what he's saying right is he saying hey
we can fix this stuff now it's not hard
to fix texas here um i think that's what
he's saying
he says uh
uh he tweets texas is number number one
in uninsured kids which is horrible
number one in uninsured residents which
is horrible number one in rural hospital
closures which is horrible and we're
talking about this is just how this is
just on health this list is just health
care this isn't other other problems
that like the power grid and stuff that
he's wanting to fix it's just healthcare
they're number 50 and access to
prenatal and
maternal care number 50 across and
access to mental health care and he's
really been hitting the mental health
care thing a lot because we have mental
health care problems in this country
and we've seen it now with
some of these you know crazy kooks um
just absolutely barraging the internet
with crazy q and on conspiracy theories
i mean we need mental health care in
this country not just in the state of
texas but everywhere fast i mean it is
really uh affecting people and this
right-wing media has taken advantage of
these people who who definitely have
some um problems that need to be helped
with mental health care they really need
some mental health care i mean it is
crucial that we get this to these people
but i mean and he really talks about
that because i think a lot of people are
concerned about mental health care
coming out of the pandemic i think a lot
of people realize how important mental
health care is um but he says at the
bottom here we're going to expand
medicaid
bring 10 billion dollars a year back to
texas and help more people get the care
they need so here he is again and i've
said this before
he has when he's talking
when he does his speeches or when he's
when he's tweeting
um beto has a way of talking about
community and it's all about texas and i
think that's the thing that texas really
appreciates about him here other than
his opponent greg abbott who can't focus
on anything but
getting money from the nra and telling
women what the hell they can and can't
do with their bodies
yeah
i have to tell you that's one of the
things i absolutely love about beto is
that he's actually a genuine individual
and he approaches things you know a lot
of politicians are
straight-up sociopaths they are i mean
it takes
this stuff hits you and it sticks with
you know that we cover a lot of heavy
stuff man and we're real people and it
can really get you down you know i mean
it can weigh on you after a while
and and
a lot of
it doesn't bother these people like
marco rubio or
marjorie taylor greene or lauren bobert
because they're freaking sociopaths that
don't nothing sticks to him but
you know beto really gives a [ __ ] so
when
you know like we talked about i think it
was last week or week before we were
talking about that [ __ ] application
that abbott sent in that he knew was
going to fail for medicare
and that hit beto o'rourke right in the
heart
because
i mean look at these statistics i mean
everybody thinks texas is rich because
we have oil we are not we are not the
income disparity is huge in texas and
these statistics are just horrifying
50th in access to prenatal and maternal
care
that's horrible yeah well and not only
that not only that they're limiting it
just through laws
for people to make their own choices in
that in that access that they do that
limited access that they do have which
is kind of pathetic but you know and in
that condition and in that state that
we're in now
we take our tax money and send it to the
federal government and we are we're a
net contributor we're not one of the red
states that is
you know uh uh
the wealth i call them the welfare red
states that they're they're governors
that run their budgets off of the
federal government because they don't
take in enough taxes to pay their own
bills let alone chip in to help out
we're actually a net contributor
so instead of taking the matching funds
for medicare
back here where we desperately need it
that's what i was trying to point out
when we were having that discussion is
how desperately needed we we needed that
medicare and how cruel it was for abbott
to do that
i mean
of the republican party i mean for for
years and years and years after the aca
which most people know it as obamacare
but the affordable care act was was
enacted um the the mechanism to deliver
states the money for the aca
for medicaid and medicare but mostly
medicaid relief um inside those packages
for the aca was that the states had to
adopt
those measures and a lot of republican
legislators said no we don't want your
money so basically
they were taking they were taking money
from the state giving it to the federal
government the federal government said
hey we will give you this money back
plus some for your medicaid for your
citizens for your health care mental
health care prenatal i mean you name it
because it was medicaid funding some
medicare but mostly medicaid state
funding for folks who can't afford
health care and this and the republicans
in those states said ah [ __ ] you we
don't want your money our people don't
want your money and we definitely don't
want to give
the people the money that they deserve
through this legislation and really
honestly a lot of voters went along with
it because they called it obamacare they
demonized it
i mean hell they even they even got them
to vote for donald trump to actually cut
the goddamn thing which is crazy to
watch
this on this list about the rural
hospitals because they're number one in
rural hospital closures because the aca
one of the one of the things that it did
so well in the states that actually
adopted the medicaid expansion because
in rural areas i don't know if folks
know this but white people in rural
areas use more medicaid dollars than any
other demographic in this country and
and the reason why is because they're
they have such scarce area there's not a
lot of factories in those parts of the
country anymore there's not a lot of
jobs it's poverty stricken and they rely
on rural hospitals to get funding from
the government to keep it open so that
people in those areas have access to
health care so they voted against their
entire interest where the aca that was
the aca did a lot of things bad you know
it didn't do it well right but one thing
that the aca did really well where the
states expanded their medicaid is they
were able to keep a lot of their rural
hospitals open it was states like texas
missouri some other states that really
that really uh you know went the
opposite direction of medicaid expansion
where these rural hospitals were closed
and it affects those citizens in those
states but i think they're waking up to
it texas but i think people are finally
seeing that hey there are people out
here who give a [ __ ] about us like beto
who want to talk about this stuff where
greg abbott wants to talk about how how
great it is that you got guns i mean
yeah when you when your kids got a 102
fever at two o'clock in the morning that
that ar-15 is not going to do [ __ ] for
you you're going to have to you know
this hit me personally we had a hospital
15 minutes up the road
in a little town called gilmer
it's shut down it's gone it's gone now
now if someone in that area
in my area
has an emergency
it's 30 minutes to the closest hospital
and then if you want to go to a real
level one trauma center if you've got a
real problem i mean
you know i mean you're talking about
there are some bad car wrecks out in
rural texas because it's not well lit
and
and a lot of dwi's and stuff out here i
mean you get some bad car accidents
man you are 45 minutes away from the
first level one trauma center
and
that's a recipe for death right there
because if you need a level one trauma
center
you have you need it now you know you
don't need it 45 minutes from now
yeah but texas paul but texas paul
there's woke people out there trying to
get these hospitals it's woke-ism right
it's the mother wokers out there i mean
this is really why it is so easy and i
don't i i think i think democrats are
doing a better better job every single
day really every single minute of
getting people in this country to
realize that when these people are
standing around talking about woke-ism
and woke [ __ ] and all this and
worrying about people's genitalia and
who who they love and what books you're
going to read not going to read people
are going way to say it like we're
worried about damn hospital closing i'm
worried about not being able to get
access to my health care i want to make
sure the school has enough goddamn money
to operate to make sure that it's safe
from the governor that letting 18 year
olds go
use a credit card to buy up weapons to
murder 19 children like these things
these things actually affect these
people and if we just and i know it i
know it sounds you know everyone thinks
it's gross but i say it here i don't
care we have to politicize these issues
we have to lean into democracy and i
really think that o'rourke and well and
even john fetterman is doing a great job
in pennsylvania of of this brand of
leaning into democracy leaning into it
not leaning away from it not running
from the the woke and all that crap um
just completely leaning into it i mean
really honestly paul if you think it's
do you think it's woke and i don't know
really what what they're talking about
anymore but do you think it's woke to
want a hospital in your rural area do
you think that's woke i don't know
absolutely i do
absolutely i do because i happen to know
what the definition of woke is and yeah
i'm completely aware we really need
right
our hospital wasn't it was like a if i
remember correctly it was a level four
center it wasn't it wasn't it was not
for
severe horrible you know okay we got
somebody coming in with a missing arm
that's not what they did there but you
know
if you had if you needed stitches or you
had a broken arm or you had a
sick kid with a fever or something like
that it was right there and it really
helped
these
trauma centers that were dealing with
these horrible issues well now they're
dealing with all of them and beto is
just i'm so proud of him i am so proud
of him he has just been textbooked in
exactly what you're talking about
he takes these people that come in to
heckle them and cause problems at his
rallies and he says okay
tell me what you think he doesn't just
let him sit there and and and be jerks
about it talk talk to me talk to me tell
me what you think and then i'll tell you
where i'm at and they're like oh
wow
okay
right why you what
right one of the greatest videos is
there was there was a trump supporter
she shows up at the rally she has a
manga hat on and and i believe she's
asking him i don't remember exactly what
issue but he talked to her in the crowd
in the and he's not even on rallies or
like community halls right like it's not
even like this big huge arena that he's
just that he's just putting on a comedy
show like like trump does right he's
actually going and talking to people and
and of course these p these places are
crowded and the overflows are full
because they're really small that's the
intention because he wants to talk to
people but this one where she's wearing
a manga hat and by the end she comes up
to him to take a picture and he signs he
signs the bill of her of her maga hat
which is and then she puts it on which
is incredible which is it just it just
goes to show and i i've tried to say
this for for as long as we've been on
the air which uh we're at episode
216 or something like that i've been
trying to say it over and over and over
again that look it's not about really
what you say it's how you say it and and
a lot of times if you're saying
something the way that people want to
hear it that is important because then
you can deliver the message that people
need to hear as opposed to this queuing
on garbage and all this nonsense about
about oh we're butt hurt because people
are calling us fascists because we are i
want to bring in
our
our our executive producer and co-host
gabe sanchez
gabe how are you this morning uh not
butt hurt
not butter for being called the fascist
oh come on
um
yeah i mean well no i think yeah you're
right you got to call them out every
single day every every type of bull
don't do not give them an inch because
they will take a mile
oh yeah one and that's that's what we
try to do here two hours every single
day is to is to call them out call out
their [ __ ] politicize every single
issue if we can and give you the ammo
that you need to go out and talk about
this stuff
because that o'rourke is actually going
to set policy so he has to go out and he
has to actually communicate to the
communities about the community policy
that he wants to set if they were to
elect him right but here on this show
we've got to do it on a national
spectrum we've gotta we've gotta do
these things and to watch oh my god to
watch charlie kirk cry
on fox news texas paul to watch him cry
on fox news when when joe biden didn't
even call him a nazi because that's what
i would call charlie kirk to his face if
i was if i if i was within spitting
distance of charlie kirk i totally would
call him a nazi but
joe biden calls maca republicans
semi-fascist and he's just he's offended
he's a completely offended it was
it's it's a sight to see i'm gonna show
it here but what's your thoughts on
these people now being butthurt about
being called names i guess because
they're
they're they're weak
well you know i want to expand on what
gabe just said right there he just
nailed it you know we we have
for so long this this this was the
problem and this is what i talk to my
people about all the time that watch my
videos and follow my shows is that for
the longest time we
when they go low we go high
and that's [ __ ] that is [ __ ]
we have to
we have to slug it out we allowed
ourselves
to say okay we'll run on our ideas and
we allowed the other side to have this
culture war
and we didn't want to get down into it
well we have to and like you say every
day we have to politicize it every day
we have to swing at these people we have
to call them what they are don't be
polite about it and say well there are
definitely some republicans we can work
with no no you're you're [ __ ] fascist
that's what you are
you're [ __ ] fascist and the ones that
aren't calling fat the fascists out well
you're you're you're fascist also
because you're allowing it to happen
you know and if charlie kirk wants to be
butthurt about this and have a tantrum
bring it you want to throw rocks when
you live in a glass house come on man
this is a conversation i want to have
well i think you're right i think
charlie
and gabe i know you have some feelings
on this but i think charlie here um he
he really did not do himself a favor by
whining and crying let's take a look at
this
um
um on fox news i'm not sure which trader
tv show this is it looks like someone's
filling in for laura ingraham the the of
the the uh the
born and raised nazi apparently but uh
of course
they had the ghoul stephen miller on
here on this on this panel to to defend
that they're not fascist here's stephen
miller is
he's the one designed and him and
charlie kirk are designed to defend that
they're not fascist who is this guy in
the middle does anyone know this guy is
that that is frightened yeah you talking
about kirk i think i'm not sure yeah
yeah
no no no no
the guy in the middle here he looks
frightened that he that he's in between
uh two fascists and he's about to try to
uh justify a way that he's not a fascist
yeah but charlie i'm blanking on his
name but he is a right wing of course he
is yeah he goes fascist yeah i mean he
he does he does go after people for the
kind of
vile things but yeah he looks paranoid
for sure is it kind of funny how they're
like you know what we're gonna get we're
gonna get people to come on here and
defend our or beat back against the word
fascist who should we have on well who's
the most fascist we can find they're
like oh well let's bring those people on
here is um here is human plate face uh
charlie kirk um talking about how he's
really upset and you know what i'm
rubber you're glued nah man of boo boo
sticks to you let's listen you have to
remain peaceful on our side but i do
think that if they're gonna escalate the
language then game on like okay if
you're gonna call us a bunch of fascists
we're not gonna take that anymore you're
the fascist joe biden and there's other
words we could use as well we're not
gonna be like well oh he would use the
word nazi oh my god is that what he's
saying because that's what he's saying
right yeah i think well i think what
he's describing is you know
self-fulfilling prophecy right he's like
if you call us this
then we will
we will double down on the thing that
you you claim that we are we will be the
bad guys it's like one of those people
it's like
when somebody gets called out and like
oh that's what you guys want us to be
then we'll just do it we'll just do it
right and they'll use that as an excuse
to be like well you guys want us to do
it it's like no you wanted to do it we
called you out
and you said well cat's out of the bag
now and that's what's happening here so
he's like oh we could call him very bad
words much worse than fascists we could
do this we could do that it's like yeah
we know because you guys are these
things they already do want to do them
you're just looking for an excuse to
make it okay and acceptable
um oh and the guy in the middle is uh is
kurt
schlinker oh he's a he's a speaker
well he's a total he's a total dick bag
he uh he goes and he attacks people he's
right-wing he's
irrelevant in many ways he looks like a
bag of dicks i'm just saying look at him
he's he's really he's not like i mean
that's a great that's a great snapshot
that you have right there that you
haven't stopped right
with this with this i have now texas
paul what's funny about this little
tantrum that charlie's having here is
that there was an event called cpac down
in your state uh just just i think was
under a month ago and they actually had
up on the screen and said we are all
domestic terrorists like what the [ __ ]
are you kidding me and your butt hurt
that that that joe biden's calling you a
semi-fascist when you're
self-proclaiming that you people are
domestic terrorists give me a [ __ ]
break
yeah
that was hilarious i mean you've got to
have a picture of that banner if you're
going to bring that up that was just
this was not faked folks i mean they
really across the main banner above
their stage
was
we are
domestic terrorists
they were so proud of what they said out
loud they said it out loud too
constantly during the entire cpac they
constantly leaned into the fact that
yeah we're domestic terrorists we we
were there on on january 6th
i i guess it's not blm and antifa
anymore i guess they're proud of it now
but yeah
well that was hilarious talking about
the
the biggest cell phone of the century
let me
right i mean it's you know it's non-stop
every day whether it's the you know the
the trump mar-a-lago search from the fbi
and then making all these excuses and
continuously getting owned it's them
admitting that they're domestic
terrorists you know or is them
you know like charlie kirk admitting
that they're fascist or or at least
admitting by accepting the role that
they've been assigned by society it's
like no one no one assigned this role to
you you actively chose right to be this
[ __ ] human being
and we're just shedding light on it well
i also want to point out that at charlie
kirk's little turning point usa student
thing where he invited the the the uh
accused pedophile matt gatz to come and
frolic with the students there were
there were actual nazis outside
like with flags in support of charlie
and his organization they weren't there
to protest him they were there because
they enjoyed turning points
they love it down there yo i mean do you
all remember charlottesville i mean
there was a group there that at the time
called themselves identity europa they
were one of the big
sponsors of that now they call
themselves the american identity
movement these groups keep rebranding
i mean vanguard was the same way they
rebranded it became patriot front which
i got agree this group
this group got hacked
and their internal communications
uh one of them that just stuck with me
was
infiltrating the gop is broke
infiltrating turning point usa is woke
they have decided instead of going to
the barrel they're going to go to the
tree
and they are they are sending people
into these organizations like turning
point usa
uh to recruit
they are i mean they said it themselves
that they're doing that now turning
point usa
avidly denies this but then you have
people like crystal clanton that was
working there and i don't know if you
know anything about that scandal but
that one goes all the way to clarence
thomas he's still that today have you
heard about that that that no i think
you sent me an article on that this
morning i haven't i haven't had a chance
oh my goodness she got okay she she had
text messages where she said i hate
black people
she got caught they fired her okay
you're talking about it she worked for
turning points usa she was a staffer or
something she was
right they bragged about her like crazy
she was a higher level
executive at turning point usa she gets
fired
jenny thomas loves this girl
loves her so much she moved her into her
house and hired her after she gets fired
from turning point usa for saying i hate
black people wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait this yeah this this does sound very
familiar
yeah you're saying a turning point usa
staffer who is caught texting she hates
black people goes and lives in jeannie
thomas's house the wife of clarence
thomas right for a year okay okay well
i'm just checking
this is what's coming out they found
letters
because now get this you'll never
believe where chris crystal clanton is
now
she is
a clerk for federal judge william pryor
oh i'm sure it's i'm sure it's not a
trump appointed judge i'm sure that's
not the case it gets better though it
keeps getting better people were like
how did this woman end up clerking for a
federal judge well they found letters
from clarence thomas that of course
recommended her to go to law school
um and and and helped her get into law
school and then they found letters
helping her get the job with william
pryor
and now it's a big stink's coming out
because people are like why the hell are
you hiring this woman for such a chris a
federal
judge clerkship is prestigious
it's a stepping stone to a
and this is where it gets really bad
it's a stepping stone to a
supreme court clerkship
in the letters that they found from
thomas
he says
he's grooming her to be his clerk
i mean if you cannot make
grooming
yes grooming her to be his clerk if she
does well in her job for william pryor
he's going to hire her for a clerk he's
going to give her a clerkship in the
supreme court
here
uh
crystal clinton um clarence thomas's
wife's assistant apparently it's or her
assistant is that right served as
turning points usa candace this was back
and and this is back in 2019 so this is
stuff like people have been talking
about this for a little bit now
um
so i just wanted to give context put a
kind of a face to the name that we're
talking about right now but here's
apparently the quote from the text
message she sent she said
i hate black people like [ __ ] them all i
hate blacks end of story is what the
quote is here now again i don't know but
this is a picture
of uh her with
jeannie thomas and with clarence thomas
here
which is yeah they're holding a bottle
of wine it looks you know it looks kind
of weird that's their house by the way
that's that's their virginia home oh she
lives there she lived there for a year
so this is the home where she had
resided with them i guess
yeah and
what what gets even better where this
circles back to charlie kirk and what
we're talking about is see when charlie
kirk fired her
he's like i don't want to talk about
this we don't have a
nazi problem at turning point usa see we
took decisive action that was his quote
we took decisive action within 72 hours
and we fired this person well now that
he found out that clarence thomas loves
her
and is
protecting her and grooming her he
doesn't want to be in conflict with the
supreme court justice so now
charlie kirk has come up with a
ridiculous story that when he said that
and this is recent this is this is not
2019 stuff this is recent he has
completely changed his story that that
statement that i took decisive action
and fired
this person within 72 hours well i
wasn't talking about crystal clanton
i was because she was set up there was a
rogue employee that we haven't heard
anything about we don't know who this
rogue employee supposedly is that hacked
her they hacked her and they said
they always played the victims and they
always said i was hacked that's who i
was taking decisive action about because
i fired that employee within 72 hours i
didn't mean crystal clanton yeah of
course he let that sit out there since
2019 and not said a word but now that
you know
she's
i don't even know the white video put it
clarence thomas's pet or whatever
now charlie kirk
is totally backstepping and oh yeah
crystal clanton's great she never did
anything she loves
her right then why did you fire her and
that'll be the next thing that changes
is we didn't fire her she just took a an
opportunity to work with jenny thomas or
something like that right well you know
this is the same story across the board
with these right wingers um we we talked
to dakota adams and tasha
adams who who are the estranged wife and
a strange son of stuart rhodes the
founder of the oath keepers and they
even described us in our first interview
like how the oath keepers got started
and what stewart tried to do to keep the
the fascist the white supremacists out
of his group because he understood one
thing about paramilitary groups is they
eventually become infiltrated and taken
over by white supremacists and he tried
his damndest like for years and years
and years stewart rhodes believe it or
not try this damned us to keep racist
and white supremacists and neo-nazis out
of his paramilitary group the oath
keepers but it's inevitable like there's
nothing you can do when you when you
spread right-wing fascism no matter how
little or how much
when you're doing these things you're
only inviting those people to take over
your groups and turning points usa is no
different than the oath keepers um a
cpac is no different than the proud boys
i mean it literally these white
supremacists these terrorists they take
over these groups they infiltrate them
and they become part of their power and
the reason why they become part of their
power is because of the recruitment like
you were saying texas paul because
that's one reason why stewart rhodes was
led down this road after donald trump
was elected because it became so easy to
elect people on fear and hatred and
bigotry it was so easy that they
actually became the terrorists
themselves and now they declare
themselves here's a video from that cpac
event that we were talking about earlier
this is [ __ ] real this is not made up
much they did this themselves this is
legitimate right and then this is the
video of it listen to the announcement
here
ladies and gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists
please welcome founder of this
that now i wanna i wanna i want you to
hear it again but but listen there is
there there's a woman in front of a
microphone who is reading a script to
announce these people can you imagine
when she gets the script of we are all
domestic terrorists she's like wait what
but you want me to read this out loud
into the damn microphone
i can't even she's like we gotta we got
a last minute change in the script she's
like okay all right i mean
now we'll be pray for what the [ __ ]
but she also says it so
calmly right what she i mean she did not
she did it professional um now i don't
know who this announcer is but boy did
she have to really uh look deep inside
let's let's listen to it one more time
ladies and gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists
please welcome and there's like i don't
know a couple you know there's tens of
people in this
not photoshopped people that's real that
is not
real that is like we're being
tongue-in-cheek it's like why would you
why would you even want to
like
cross that line like if you want to be
tongue-in-cheek about other things
okay sure but when you're talking about
something like this like we're you are
you are giving a line that is you know
admitting to being domestic terrorist
and what they say oh it was a joke we
were being you know coy with it or what
it's like
there's a big difference between
saying what you said
and making a joke of it right like
especially when these are people who 100
believe
to the millionth degree that everything
that comes out of any of their mouths
from the republican party is truth
they they're the same people who believe
what comes out of tucker carlson's mouth
from his entertainment show they're the
same people who believe what come out of
trump's mouth which is like when people
like oh he was being sarcastic you know
when people are trying to defend his
racism or defend his his bigoted remarks
or whatever it might be the immediate
response from the right is oh you guys
you guys i obviously don't understand
comedy you don't understand sarcasm he
was being slight with his words like
yeah okay
you know i don't remember you remember
this cpac was in 2020 or i think it was
in 2020 or 2021 where they had the the
the nazi symbol as the stage like that
was 2021 because it was it was
there were two events that happened it
was one after another there was one in
2020 and i i'm blanking on what it was
and then 2021 happened
and it was the uh they're not home let
me let me look up what happened to 2020
because there was another one that was
like nazi related but but this is this
gorban who is a self-professed white
supremacist i mean right victor orban
the the
head of of uh hungary the the president
of hungary
yeah prime minister hungary pardoned me
um
is a self-professed white supremacist he
he doesn't make any bones about it and
he was keynote speaker at cpac last year
i mean or this
yeah well this one that that's the one
that they were here in dallas yeah yeah
which is which is uh even more crazy
that they had a real life fascist
dictator from from europe come over here
and speak at their domestic terrorist
rally which is kind of crazy it's it
well i mean it's not kind of crazy it's
it's par for the course and that's why
that's why when you see charlie kirk
whining and crying about jill biden
calling him semi-fascists you should
kind of laugh because they've done this
to themselves right paul i mean they've
done this to themselves
absolutely and and you know
when we talk about charlie kirk throwing
stones
well
let's do this
your group
has been
absolutely following putin's playbook
100
they've taken their young volunteers and
people you need to know this if your
kids are in college and high school and
there's a turning point usa
uh
chapter there
they are all over the country there are
literally thousands upon thousands of
these chapters now all over they've they
made a point of getting into every
college campus every junior college
campus everywhere they are using your
kids
to do the same thing that putin did with
his troll farms they're using them they
they give them a social media
script
and they have them go out into social
media and spread misinformation
disinformation and pro
fascist pro-gop [ __ ] all over the
internet they are using these kids as a
troll farm
and it's it's disgusting they're really
doing this well turning points usa is
not only not only are they well
organized they're well funded if you go
um because we've had ben glebe on the
show and we've had rachel bittikoffer
who would both
uh
you know rachel's a great friend of the
show and been now too but um they both
had debated charlie kirk on his debate
night that he has at his at his turning
points usa in phoenix and when and when
uh when you go to his complex in phoenix
it's like a [ __ ] three-story building
this isn't like some kind of shanty out
in the middle of nowhere this [ __ ]
place is like three stories and it's
fully staffed they have hundreds of
people on that staff that is designed
and organized to spread fascism all
around the country and that is why
charlie kirk is actually offended when
joe biden calls him a fascist because
he's like whoa
people are on to me and that's the bad
that's that's where they draw the line
is not that they're not fascist or not
that they're not right winger nazis it's
i don't want you to know that i am right
because they've always thin veiled this
fascism for years and decades and
decades with conservatism and that's
that nonsense that is starting to break
through and people are starting to see
these [ __ ] for who they are you're not
conservative you're not [ __ ] you're
farthest away from a reagan type
conservative that there is you are a god
damn maga america first nazi that is
exactly what you are when you're you
know rubbing elbows with the likes of
nick fuentes marjorie taylor green and
some of these others
well you know
if you don't mind me going back to your
comment about homer rhodes
he tried very hard to keep the out nazis
out of his group but his group was
actually founded in racism
the oath keepers started down here in
texas
on the border
that's that's what they started as is
they were going to be a private militia
to patrol the border
and
so they tried desperately to keep
anybody with
direct ties you know somebody that they
like the southern poverty law center
could identify
from being part of the organization but
they themselves were just flagrant
racists oh wow these people weren't
going down and standing in 100 plus
degree heat let me tell you
south texas is a desert it is the mexico
badlands okay it's it's the sonoran
desert these these fat asses were not
going down there and standing in 100 520
110 degree heat because they they were
afraid you know because they had a
legitimate beef
what drove that was racism
and that's what stewart rhodes was
trying to cap was not that racist was in
his group he just didn't want people
publicly being racist they had they had
people they had people they told us his
family told us that during during his
rise as as the oath keepers spread
across the country because they were
opening chapter here and chapter there
in chapter here and the way that they
kind of did this was they did it with uh
you know veterans and and law
enforcement right that's that was kind
of their aim as opposed to paramilitary
groups
they want misfits they really don't want
institution they don't want
institutional people they want misfits
so when oath keepers took a different
direction but they were having a lot of
trouble keeping outright racist out of
their group and what i mean is is they
would have social media people that
all they did was scour their members
social media and to if they even hinted
at racism on their social media because
they didn't want to be accused of it
right and this is again this is what
we're talking about with charlie kirk is
they want to implement these policies
they want to be bigots they want to be
right-wing fascists they want to tell
women what they can and can't do they
want to take away people's vote people's
rights but they don't want anyone to
know that they're nazis right just like
you know why that is do you know why
that is
because your average republican
middle-aged white guy that looks like me
is a racist usually right they usually
are i i'm you know i'm not scared to say
it republicans
i would probably guess 90 of them are
racist they'll tell you they aren't
and that's where that line splits
he can get money out of these people for
doing racist things like they were doing
down at the border
you know because then they can call it
well oh border security this happened
the other but the minute that you have
actual nazis in your organization that
are out
then these people that are racist
they're like okay that's too far you
right i don't want to be gonna find me
as a racist i don't want to be known as
a racist well that's why charlie
that's why charlie and the turning
points usa people were so terrified and
the event organizers were terrified at
that event in florida when the let's go
brandon desantis nazi showed up because
they were desantis nazis i mean we know
in florida there are outright neo-nazis
that support ron desantis and they love
ron desantis and ron desantis will not
speak against them at all and the reason
why
right well i mean he wants to ignore
that they even exist but they definitely
exist right and i think and i think
that's the point here is that charlie
kirk again just like stewart rhodes are
just like rhonda santos they're not butt
hurt that someone's calling them a
fascist they just don't want their their
donor block to believe it because if
they believe it they might get peeled
off they might lose
a bit of that and i want to i want to
make something clear i you know i would
i will admit that not you know this is
like a square rectangle kind of theory
here right like from if everyone
remembers geometry
not
all republicans are fascist or racist
but all fascist and racist are
republicans republicans right so like
let's keep like i'm i don't i don't know
not the word group or whatever but like
even the fact that some of these people
like charlie kirk and others
were like uh you know offended at the
fact that it wasn't full-on racist right
it was or full-on fascist it was
semi-fascist right they they hated the
idea of any i mean which should be the
normal response of anyone like oh [ __ ]
no i'm not a fascist
charlie's response was and all these
other people are going to be like
uh it's not that we're not fascist it's
if you want us to be a fascist we'll do
we'll be a fascist out in the open
because you want us you need a you need
a boogie man you need a monster it's
like no you were already those things we
just [ __ ] turned the room light on
and showed everyone who you really were
and what your true colors were um so
they will use that as an excuse
and you'll see that be like well they
they want us to be this thing let's
let's let's really be that thing
and here's a piece of tape from uh
from charlie kirk's uh older brother the
bowtie rube tucker carlson from white
privilege tonight um let's listen to
what they have to say here on tucker's
show this is back in march about fascism
the right is going to pick a fascist
within 10 to 20 years because they're
not going to be and what turned out to
be one of the most chilling statements
ever made i mean that is that is
chilling when they say yeah the right
within 10 or 20 years but he didn't even
he just agreed with it he didn't be like
oh that's that's bad for the party we
shouldn't have that like that that that
is something that we should totally
you know disavow and make sure that we
don't have within the republican party
he goes yeah yeah that'll probably
happen well but i mean the thing is is
that like like you made the point
earlier texas paul the people like like
uh tucker carlson hail vladimir putin
which is really gross i'm going to show
some of that video in the shitless round
up here but he also he also
loves victor orban i mean he went over
to hungary and gave him fellatio pretty
much for his tv show to to the to the
hungarian fascist the hungarian hitler
that is orban
yeah that that interview was disgusting
that if you saw the one where he
actually sat down with orban
that was disgusting i mean this man is a
i mean he is brutal he is brutal yeah
not only does he not only is he a racist
but he hates the lgbtq community i mean
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah they they they
kill gay people in hungary they do
i mean this is no joke about it they say
well we're going to send them to prison
but they always end up at this
they end up dead and right well they're
they're barreling down this same kind of
road here in this in this country when
when they when they're talking about
ostracizing uh people who identify as
certain things like leave people to [ __ ]
alone would you please and i think
that's the most important part and i
want to end here because we're gonna
have to go to break and go to the
shitless roundup is texas paul tell us
tell the people out there because you
know we talk about it here is leaning
into democracy because uh lindsey graham
talks about riots but i actually don't
think that's how they're gonna try to
take over this country they're gonna do
it inside our government so we shouldn't
worry so much about violence in the
streets we should worry about these
fascists in our government so tell them
how to lean into democracy and give them
an idea what they can do to really save
our democracy
well look folks this is really simple
this is really simple the ballot box
right now today still matters
if we don't show up and vote
next election it won't
it won't if you give republicans power
our democracy goes down the toilet so
do these things
volunteer save democratic candidates
money
save them money from having to pay
people to do things phone bank for them
you can phone bank nationwide on a cell
phone with no long distance fees
whatsoever
knock on doors for a candidate
find money i mean find it anywhere you
can and send it i don't like money in
politics you don't like money in
politics but the ads are not free and
this is how the game works now so we
have to fight the way the rules are set
now
so fun the hell out of your your
democratic candidates ones that you like
nationwide and your local candidates the
house races and
right now we're coming coming up against
the deadline in a lot of states
for registration
in the state of texas they've been
kicking people off the voter rolls so
you have to check your registration now
so that you have time to fix it if
they've screwed with you
because it's an entire process to get
these things get yourself back on the
voter registration rules
your state will have
a a website that you can go to
there there's a there's a gov
website here in texas you can go to to
check your registration i'm sorry i
don't have it memorized but it it's the
first one that pops up when you google
it
check your registration and more than
anything
if you have to crawl over
burning
broken glass to vote
if you have to lose your job to take the
day off to vote
whatever it takes our country's in
danger folks you have to vote and you
have to vote democrat the entire ticket
up and down we have to end the
republican party
because they are openly
embracing fascism they are openly
telling you
we are going to do this we are going to
be a fascist government because we want
to be a christo-fascist
white nationalist government
period
they're not hiding it it is what they
are telling you they're going to do it's
not just me telling you we show you
every week
tony michaels puts on one of the
greatest podcasts there is out there
because he and gabe sit there and they
show you these people out of their
mouths
every
damn
day
what these people say
and they're telling you and like maya
angelou said when somebody tells you who
they are
believe them
we have to vote it's the most important
thing you're going to do in your life
this year
so everybody go out get registered to
vote check your registration check your
family your friends registration make
sure they know to check their
registration if they're not registered
find them a way to get registered
registered in the vote phone bank give
money whatever you can do to lean into
your democracy and engage in your ballot
because your way of life depends on it
texas paul it's tuesday thanks for
joining us buddy i love having you here
on tuesday
everyone go follow texas paul go to the
midas touch network channel as well
you'll see all texas paul's reacts there
as well he's a midas mighty favorite
texas paul my friend
it said it's been great to talk to you
i'll i'll talk to you later on i'm sure
in in the dm's in private so absolutely
and matt take two seconds to make a plug
absolutely go ahead sir
go to texaspalmers.com and buy a shirt
or a mug
i'm gonna shamelessly push my
merchandise because i'm telling you
i take a very small portion of that and
a big portion of it goes to pay for
those great ads that midas touch is
putting out and this last two months
i hate to keep going back to money folks
but
money is huge they just poured 20 the
republicans just poured 20
million dollars into florida because val
dimmings is kicking the [ __ ] out of
marco rubio and desantis is in trouble
with charlie crist charlie crist came
out swinging please folks
buy the merchandise i know
everybody hates money in politics but
god dawg it man it is it is the weapon
we have besides our vote it is
we'll go
go to texas paul was it texas paul merch
dot com is that what it is texas paul
merch dot com texas paul merch dot com
go follow texas paul and all the the
socials the tweety tweets the tiki talks
and the instagrammies go follow them
there american made a union american
american-made products only
well texaspaul merch.com texas paul
thank you we'll see you next tuesday my
friend everyone stick around we'll be
right back right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
yours
bomb
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show texas fall
tuesday
tuesday you got tacos you got texas paul
you got us for two goddamn hours
just like every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11th central
ninth pacific on youtube twitter twitch
and simulcasting from the minus touch
facebook page
holy [ __ ] there's a lot of video to get
through gig holy moly the reason why i
played the trucker convoy
is because uh lindsey graham we know
yesterday said something about riots and
everyone's kind of freaking out i've had
some people personally
like send me a message back oh are you
scared of the violence and i'm like well
there's gonna be a little violence but
you gotta remember
this is the distraction right they're
trying to distract us that there's gonna
be violence so that they can take over
the government they've already tried the
violent way of taking over the
government and it didn't [ __ ] work it
didn't work at all
um
our government stood the constitution
stood
we we elected joe biden joe biden was
sworn in he's the president of the
united states and there ain't a goddamn
thing you can do about it even if you
want to wave your hand over declassified
documents and wave that magic wand and
go give me a re-election please give me
a re-election please
um so there's probably going to be a
little bit of violence because they're
violent [ __ ] that's just the
way it is well remember i mean anytime
that any time republicans you know like
ted cruz lindsey graham donald trump uh
josh hawley like any of these people
whenever they do not get what they want
whenever they are denied what they
believe is their right or they're told
that they're wrong or they lost or
whatever might be
their immediate go-to
is to act like thugs and threaten
violence
which is funny because that's exactly
what they accuse democrats of doing
right so the project slam
rejection is a hell of a drug i mean
antifa is trending this morning but
here's the thing here's what i want
everyone to understand
is that their their calls for violence
is to get inside your head and to [ __ ]
with your thought process to think that
the the actual threat is a bunch of
[ __ ] gravy seals out in the streets
think about this for a second think
about what it would take at this point
during a midterm think about this during
a [ __ ] midterm to take over not just
the federal government which is in all
50 states
but also state governments county
governments
i mean local governments school boards
with violence think about that think
about how how many people you think
there's that many trump supporters and
you think that's many how many loyal
trump supporters are [ __ ] no not even
close but what they want you to do is
they want you to be afraid of that so
that way you're not paying attention
when they win the offices inside the
federal government inside the state
government inside the county government
inside your school board healthy [ __ ]
dog catcher for that matter that's what
they don't want you to pay attention to
they want you to be scared of violence
so that way you're not paying attention
to which one of these fascists are
winning the actual power inside
inside the government that's the most
important thing here is that we have to
pay attention with to our democracy and
yes
they're they're going to there's going
to be some crazies we watched was the
cincinnati where this guy went to the
fbi thing and they they ended up yeah
cincinnati fbi is uh actually i was just
writing about that last night uh
ricky schiffer okay ricky
you know went to an fbi uh building in
cincinnati with a nail gun thinking that
he was gonna get justice for the unfair
treatment of donald trump by the fbi
but remember the big part of that story
is where was he posting all of this all
of this stuff that was that was making
death threats against the fbi i'll give
you two guesses but you only need one
tony uh probably fraud social exactly
fraud social i
i wonder if i went over and said
something or that they would censor me
um they're people are people are uh
commenting to his um
to his latest post or the one that was
yesterday or yeah yesterday i think is
he posting now i haven't i haven't been
paying i haven't checked this morning
but he had yesterday he had one
yesterday i believe it was the one which
said like
uh you've got two options
he basically tried to give the doj an
ultimatum which is like you got two
options one
is you reinstate me as president or two
we say the 2020 election is just totally
we wipe it clean we see it never it
never was you wave your hands over
so those are two things that he
basically posted on true social assuming
like he assumes that the post on
truth social that he makes are
are truth they are absolute they cannot
uh they're absolute resolute they they
cannot be broken he believes that that
is like a standing order
like the standing order when he's like
oh i had a standing order that said all
the documents i took as soon as i left
the white house will be declassified and
everyone's like that's that's not a
thing that works well we're going to see
a 40-page uh rebuttal from the
department of justice to his little
lawsuit that he filed for a special
master which again he walks straight
into this dumb [ __ ] corner where he
paints himself in the corner where the
department of justice gets 40 pages to
basically lay out how yes you did commit
crime yes it is a crime yes we are
investigating and yes we are going to
prosecute you and here is why i mean
basically well i'm not sure exactly what
they're going to do but they have that
opportunity to lay it out in 40 pages 40
pages is a lot of
a lot of material that is well i didn't
i don't remember how long the original
submission that they had to the to the
judge which was you know requesting the
magistrate and then when they're like oh
you have to redo it and they made the
corrections over this weekend i don't
recall how long that was however
the fact that they're like all right
cool so here's this one line where you
make this statement you make a claim now
here's [ __ ] two paragraphs
of us
dated logged receipts shown we showed up
or we contacted you 20 months
over a year and a half we we contacted
you'd be like can we get this [ __ ] and
you said you didn't have it and we said
are you sure you don't have it and you
said yeah we don't have it if we had it
we would have given it to you but gabe
don't you think that this federal judge
this trump appointed judge put herself
in this position what's her [ __ ] name
um
i don't know what her name is and i
forget what cannon or some [ __ ] the
point is is this she's put herself in
this position what she should have done
is took that motion that he filed in her
court and said no this is not the right
court i'm not the right judge you need
to take it somewhere else you're in the
wrong court but she has basically in her
trying to [ __ ] give him what he
wanted she's basically set him up to be
dunked here and really honestly there's
not going to be much she's going to look
like a fool too because the department
of justice is going to make her look
like a fool with her ruling so far and
say
i can't they're going to basically say i
can't even believe you've you've even
gave him the [ __ ] room to breathe on
these false [ __ ] statements when you
know it's not true and and they're just
gonna dunk on her as well as i mean it's
not they're not gonna actually dunk on
her but it is gonna be a dunk on her
it's gonna show that her incompetence so
when that came out
three days ago which is basically
showing that judge cannon was bending
over backwards to help trump right now
despite the fact that the filings that
they had were like incoherent random law
theory here they they weren't anything
it was just like a bunch of gibberish
right uh any like you said any actual
judge would say uh this is horse [ __ ]
and i would throw it out to be like why
are we wasting
money
trying to deal with this when you don't
even know what the [ __ ] you're doing
right you've got this all-star legal
team which by the way is a is it like a
a misfit cast of people that are like
uh you got alina haba who's a racist you
got christina bob you know former
employee of the raiders she's a [ __ ]
traitor right helped eastman make the
powerpoint
um
you've got uh
jim trustee who
in in a
the only way i i can imagine did you
know that he hired jim trustee after he
saw him on tv well i mean how else would
he hire him like it's like an as seen on
tv lawyer is basically what this was i
mean he saw them on like fox news or
whatever can you imagine can you imagine
if this [ __ ] writes a brief
trump and trust he tries to file like
judge joe brown or something like on the
people's court or some [ __ ] oh they try
to
oh we're gonna go on tv and we're gonna
hash this out on judge joe brown the
people's court like oh my god is that
what joe brown is it people's gord is
anyone i don't know i mean there's
there's a lot of those judges judy she's
still around all right well maybe they
could go to judy maybe jimmy would give
him yeah the light of day i would say
just you you would dunk that
[ __ ] in the chat trash but
here's the point is that really honestly
this federal judge is almost acting like
a judge judy in this way in this fake tv
court and with his tv lawyers as tv
judges it's really [ __ ] laughable and
today when the department of justice
actual professionals actual attorneys
who [ __ ] prosecute cases federal
cases in federal court are going to
write a 40-page rebuttal to his lawsuit
you are not going to have a good [ __ ]
day that is not going to be a good day
for trump so america just understand
that what they're trying to do and he's
he's pair he's saying it out loud the
only way for me to save myself is to
have a new election for me to be
president and i'm telling you it's not
the violence it's not the violence that
is going to upend our country it's if
you don't lean into democracy and you
don't actually see that hey this is a
threat to our country and i need to
engage in the ballot
i need to make sure i'm registered other
people registered i need to make sure
people know what the hell is going on
and how important this midterm is
because this midterm is the most
important election of your lifetime and
as soon as it's over as soon as it's
over the votes are counted and certified
the next one will be because they're not
going away anytime soon you'll see that
in the shitless round of today so let's
start the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends let's do some surfing let's start
the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome to the shitless round up the
part of the show where we surf the
tweety tweets and trinity trends
gabe there is no better projection that
i want to show these right-wingers
what is happening in ukraine as everyone
knows
it looks like ukraine has started to
push russia back to the border and
that's some of the news the president of
ukraine zielinski has announced this
morning that they are pushing back very
heavily um against
against the russian forces but um the
ukrainian president can't do anything
about this [ __ ] idiot here in this
country uh pushing back on
on the truth that putin is not winning
the war listen to this [ __ ] oh my god i
just i can't it's almost [ __ ]
disgusting even listen to you but you
have to hear what the hell they're
saying on fox news this is what your
grammy and grampy are listening to
and believing listen now joe biden is
calling for an unconditional surrender
from vladimir putin here's the weird
thing by any actual reality-based
measure vladimir putin is not losing the
war in ukraine okay
this is absolutely
[ __ ]
disgusting that this piece of [ __ ] who
gets paid to go on tv
and tell tell millions of people the
news
gets on tv and trying to convince them
in the moment
in the moment where vladimir putin is
most vulnerable in this war where he is
being pushed back to the border of
ukraine at this point it looks like
now i i'm sure that's going to be
several more months before ukraine is
secure
from the russian forces and to beat them
back but this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
traitor he's a goddamn traitor
to tell the american people that somehow
vladimir putin is not only losing the
war but he's winning it what a pile of
[ __ ]
putin
yeah again it's no surprise right you
got him tulsa gabbard rand paul these
are all people who are putin's puppets
donald trump again people who are
putin's puppets they will say whatever
they need to say in order to make sure
that they are safe and they've got you
know the money coming in whatever's left
from his fortune
um
but the fact that we've got people
who are willing to defend putin
is insane right because they're you know
especially for like hey guys uh you know
as a republican they say hey i'm
pro-life i want to save lives i want to
make sure that those lives are safe from
any sort of
any sort of travesty crime trauma
whatever might be
and then they go
let's just what are we doing here guys
why are we saving these lives right
let's why are we doing this let's let's
let's back a murderous dictator right
this this to me
this to me shows you more what they're
for than what they're against really and
really the narrative of anti-democracy
is the message here because i really
don't believe that they're [ __ ] huge
fans of putin what they love about putin
is putin is hellbent i mean hellbent on
tearing down liberal western democracy
like tearing it to the ground burning it
and pissing on the ashes and have a
tacocracy everywhere that is literally
what these people are getting are
jerking off about like tucker carlson
they love they love the idea of
democracy going away because democracy
delivers equality and equity like i mean
it's difficult right it's hard to get
there yeah but that's the mechanism that
does that they only like it because you
know if we can remove any power or we
can increase our power and influence
right if we can oppress others as
opposed to and at the same time to be
like oh we're the ones being oppressed
right despite the facts like you guys
are the you guys are ruling
the land right now what the [ __ ] are you
guys talking about you're not oppressed
you have more money and influence than
anyone uh any average civilian in this
country right well we're going to get to
that with ann coulter with her comment
on white people you know if you've seen
this jesus christ this [ __ ] loon
but but but
you know let's listen to let's finish up
um
tucker carlson's putin fellatio here
let's let's listen
he is winning the world no he's not
that's a [ __ ] lie he looks at that
and says we won't stop until you proffer
an unconditional surrender
what is he talking about joe biden isn't
in this war now the americans obviously
are are
very very outright in their support of
ukraine and a sovereign democracy to to
defend their democracy and defend their
country which america should be
regardless if we give them money for
tanks and weapons and that sort of thing
but we definitely if we're a part of
nato we should definitely be in support
of sovereign democracies defending
themselves from a murderous autocrat
like [ __ ] putin i mean that's kind of
the idea for i don't know
what the last [ __ ] half century and
well really 70 years has been about
it's well they they
they are too far you know we've talked
about it with brett when it came to um
when we were
live streaming the announcement that
biden gave around
um student loan forgiveness right
it's the same thing here
and and what i what i mean by that is
these people within the republican party
have doubled down they've made their bet
and that bet is on trumpism that bet is
on
uh fascism the bet is on removing the
rights
um from
from us as as citizens right
because
they follow a party that says oh women
should have this right and you shouldn't
be given that right and you shouldn't
have that right and we will decide what
you read what you wear what you practice
what you you know what religion you
follow whatever it is we want to be the
person that decides those things for you
and this is just another example
of this party
you know especially if someone of
influence who is projecting to millions
of people online and on their television
to say
this is actually the narrative this is
the narrative that republicans and the
right wing and fascists want you to
believe because it is pro-putin and
putin is actually our friend
and they are doubling they've doubled
down now they're tripling down on this
fact about we're removing restricting
any sort of say free speech rights that
you have
because
some person of higher influence or power
tells them what they should say and how
they should believe or whatever they
should do
and this is just again another example
of them doing that same thing right now
this is
this is tucker carlson using his
platform
to spread disinformation and lies about
oh putin is actually winning
which is not the case right everyone
said oh this would be 12 hours putin
would go through ukraine it would be
done yeah he was gonna win he was gonna
win this [ __ ] just by walking since it
started like if i look this up days
since
uh
russia invaded ukraine uh
six days six months right so you know
half a year we're talking right now
um which is insane
because you know ukraine is is doing far
greater than any could anyone could have
imagined and the fact that the us is
sending aid to ukraine as a pro-pro-life
gesture to make sure that these people
aren't killed in some genocide because
some crazy dictator wants to rule over
them
all of a sudden
they say oh no we can't have that so we
need to change the narrative we need to
say that actually putin's winning and we
need to say that this is all abide in
regime type of thing no it's just
they are they are an ally to us
they are our friends we should care for
the people that are
like again you know you see a big person
punching down that's not
you should not be in favor of the big
guy right right that is not what you
should be doing but republicans and
people on the right and fascist and all
these people are the ones who are on
that side they're like yeah [ __ ]
pummel them break them down well they
like they liked it
now they like to punch out amanda makes
a good point here putin is getting his
ass slapped by ukraine because zielinski
here this comment um this is from
zielinski the president of ukraine's
office and says i won't give any
specifics but we will drive the invaders
he appropriate calls them the invaders
to the border zlonski urges russians to
go home or surrender otherwise quote
they will deal with other with our
defenders who will not stop until they
liber liberate everything that belongs
to ukraine and he's talking about land
he's talking about the border um so it
appears that and the news is out of
ukraine that even though it's going to
take a bit it looks like um the
ukrainians have
the russians on the run um and they're
they're getting in a situation where
they're pushing them back to the border
so um now if the russian army looks
anything like of the shark army here in
the united states gabe are you familiar
with the shard army are you familiar
with the shark army i i believe there's
a few different branches out there right
right i've seen some training videos
yeah well there's there's there's this
one here
that um that's been going around now we
showed one the other day where they were
kind of like i don't know they didn't
have the shields and the flags and stuff
well you gotta build up they gotta get
they gotta get the movement right to
know how to do the side
side step shuffle right right and then
now they're like okay now we put up we
put on our matching
blue jackets i'm very curious to know
who is the maker of these jackets i
don't know but like because they gotta
look at me like oh we have an uh an odd
number of orders happening
these like gore-tex blue
windbreakers look at that that's what's
and
what the best part about this is the one
thing they're lacking here which i don't
understand you think these cosplay
larping idiots would would get a drum
line or something where they had the
drummers or something
right well i mean you know
you know you think they have like
battlefield drums or something right
because that's what this is literally is
larping um
well yeah it's it's just cosplay i mean
yes it is like here i don't want to
downplay
the influence that a group like
patriot front has they are bad they are
fascist they have rebranded from
vanguard who we talked about earlier
with texas paul they were in
charlottesville tiki torches those dudes
those are the people that were there at
that time they've rebranded to this
patriotic
pro-american right uh we're not racist
we're not racist but you find them at
all
different areas you know
i don't actually ever i haven't actually
heard the words out of charlie kirk's
face or mouth uh face because it's
always like right
right
but uh i don't think i've ever seen or
read
charlie kirk denounce fascism or nazis
no he just doesn't like to be called
that yeah caretaker here on twitch says
shark army no not shark
shark
is what i refer to him as um but watch
the plastic shield brigade here and do
their little techniques
[Music]
the [ __ ] knee pads and the shin
guards get me oh it's amazing it's
amazing like what are you guys doing on
your knees what the [ __ ] is this like
they're like yeah this will totally
block a bullet right i don't know
why why are you wearing knee pads when
the actual military comes in with a tank
it's not gonna stop [ __ ] when when
somebody like a you know law enforcement
says hey [ __ ] stop if they're ever in
them if they're in that confrontation
and say stop and then they shoot
none of the [ __ ] that you have in front
of you is gonna stop that bullet right
well the other thing too is they're one
trick pony because the video we watched
yesterday where they were like i don't
know they were line dancing or something
they do the same thing here just with
shields and they got a guy they got one
guy attacking their entire line as if
there's gonna be like one person against
him but watch watch the watch the
technique here it's hilarious
oh look there's a threat there is a
threat
oh no he got through though
what are we doing one of them says what
are we doing what are we doing and then
like circle back circle hold on hold on
can you go back to that okay so this is
supposed to be some person that like
breaks the line right right come through
right there's two there's three lines
there right right
you know what we need to do we need to
shove them to the back and then still
expose our backs here right now like
now they're standing there going wait a
second wait the guy's back there now
yeah
the guy's like going through like
swinging doors he's like just excuse me
gotta get through gotta get through and
then they're like yep all right cool so
we dealt with that guy and it's like
no you just let him through i thought
the whole point was that you're trying
to block people from getting through you
you just you just let someone in
to attack you from behind this makes no
[ __ ] sense not one of these
[ __ ] played football at all
like even i was just gonna say i was
just gonna say
the sidestep shuffle that they were
doing in the video that we watched
yesterday shields they're plastic
shields but they're still yeah yes but
what it reminds me of is at football
practice
doing
side shuffle and then you realign and
you're back and then you go forward and
you realign and you're just doing drills
like that's what it reminds me of like
football so when you bring that up i was
like oh yeah that's exactly what it
reminds me of doing football drills in
the summer and just going through you
know like
half you got half a half paths on and
everything you're going through and
you're doing it and then
the only difference here
is that instead of blocking and
preventing someone from from from uh you
know making your group vulnerable
you know to attack they're like yep go
down through going through yeah grab
it gets way better because they i
honestly believe there's only going to
be one person attacking them watch watch
as they as they try to figure out how to
move the lines
what are we doing
so graceful really graceful
these guys like i still don't understand
the purpose of this so of course here's
kind of a close-up of their shields and
the shot of where they're standing in
line
now here we go now there's a couple guys
here nefarious guys in mass because gabe
when you when you have when you have
people in mass they're nefarious and you
can't breathe apparently but these
people can breathe yeah because it's a
white mask i'm not really sure but let's
let's watch
oh here's the threat the threat
[Music]
all right
right right
they can't figure out which one's right
and which one's left yeah oh my god this
is hilarious
okay i just want to point out something
because i'm always having enough of this
listen
if an if an actual well-trained
marine platoon encounters these people
in a civil war
do you really think you're really done
that these [ __ ] in-cell [ __ ]
cosplay larpers are gonna have no chance
any chance
with well trained marines
this group this group of
white [ __ ] inn cells think that
they're the supreme race they're the
supreme gender you know
well you know that's that's funny you
mention that because can you imagine
watching i would love and and i even
said i even said in the tweet i'd pay
money i paid money to watch the plastic
shield brigade brigade go up against a
well-trained
us marine platoon but even better i
would raise the stakes because someone
in the comments said like a girls
volleyball team i would love to watch an
all woman's marine platoon who these
guys are like oh women shouldn't be in
the army they're weak i would love to
watch an all-woman
marine platoon just absolutely [ __ ]
liquefy these these these clocks it
would be one like
their their whole preparation of like oh
they attack we push them off it's like
you do you think
that's the only thing
that marines are any sort of uh
uh people with a military background or
train they just like oh you know what we
tried guys might as well just go back
home
no there are tactics and strategies that
they will follow say hey great we're
going to try this if it doesn't work
then we're going to resort to this and
they have contingency plans to say that
this is our strategy if this doesn't
happen if that doesn't happen if that
doesn't happen then we just [ __ ] give
up
right and just stop and go well hey we
gave it our all guys and uh you know
what we got to give it to patriot front
those guys in our plastic shields really
know how to block us oh my god the
plastic shield brigade speaking of
captain plastic shield brigade you have
sweaty jim jordan oh man he looks
terrible [ __ ] dude he is huge he looks a
hundred years in the last this
this pause on the video right now looks
like an oil painting
it looks like somebody made a goddamn
oil painting of jim jordan
and he's there and he's like all right
jim we want you to just how are you
feeling right now he's like i'm feeling
pretty scared great great let's use that
now hone in on that feeling i want to
bring in some stress he goes okay well
that's not hard he goes okay okay now
imagine imagine that your your life your
way of living is at risk and you'll go
to [ __ ] prison he goes
okay uh and he's like
it's just it's amazing it's amazing
someone pointed out in the comments does
this guy have any other tie but this one
no he doesn't he also doesn't ever wear
a suit jacket he always rolls up his
sleeves well it's really hot up and i'm
not passing legislation it's really hot
up in that [ __ ] he's sweating
he's sweating guilt is what i said watch
watch as he
oh my god this video is it it it is it
is i jim jordan is terrified
whistleblowers come to us and talk about
the political pressure they're under and
now he's four whistleblowers by the way
he's for them now they can't make up
their mind man
again
count the vote don't count the vote
right you know it's it's redact the
search warrant you know don't redact the
search warrant we're down yeah
there's high gas prices and there's not
anything it is
they they are
they know what they're doing
right because they you know they
wouldn't say that they didn't i mean
some of them are are idiots and they say
because someone else says it but
at the end of the day
the hypocrisy of the republican party is
deep
deep deep deep rooted in their dna they
do not know how to exist
without
being hypocrites
one day they're this thing or even hours
ago they were this thing and then hours
later they have a whole totally opposite
different take
you know that's what they are they're
hypocrites they project they lie well
he's projecting his fear here listen now
we see that it may be in the inspector
general's office by statute the
inspector general is supposed to provide
independent oversight of the justice
department well how can you do that if
you're participating in an investigation
sean understand what happened here the
fbi came to this okay okay jim jordan is
full of [ __ ] [ __ ] the the the
nara
wanted their [ __ ] records back they
took 20 months back they couldn't get
back
20 months ago they said hey can we give
these documents can we have them they
try that's what the department of
justice is going to lay out in this 40
pages is basically going to say look you
are full of [ __ ] [ __ ] you broke the
law by not cooperating and not giving
these records back and that's why we had
to get involved the reason why jim
jordan that the inspector
general is involved in investigation is
because it's an investigation who of
someone who has stole
documents from them
from them from the government it's an
investigation on them
you dumb [ __ ] there is you do
not have to investigate the
investigation that is not a thing that
you have to do these people always do
this oh you have to investigate the
investigation which yes everyone should
be held accountable but the oversight is
not is not on the department of justice
the department of justice was asked
by nara to get involved because the
president of the united states the
former president united states donald
trump would not give them their [ __ ]
back and it became a criminal matter
that is why you dumb [ __ ] and
he's sweating here because i think jim
jordan has more to do with this document
than what is being exposed oh yeah and
let's not forget he's got his own
personal [ __ ] going right which is
george clooney and hbo by the way
uh bought the rights for the documentary
so this isn't just like some fairy tale
like i wish he'll make this documentary
about jim jordan the sexual assault uh
situation with the wrestling team it is
100 happening and they are working
together so just wait i mean the fact he
cuz he's probably also potentially
hearing things like oh you know george
clooney or the team came through and
they asked so-and-so some questions they
asked so-and-so to give a statement they
asked so-and-so and he's like oh [ __ ] my
personal life is [ __ ] my professional
life is [ __ ] i'm all all over just
[ __ ]
well and he was he was humping for
pardons for him and others oh yeah well
he was he was he was well he was like
can i get an update on that problem
well let's listen to him sweat here the
inspector general said we're going to
we're going to take the phone sitting
member of congress we're going to take
yeah because he committed crime rated
president trump's home and we're going
to do it while the congressman perry is
on vacation you seem scared the
inspector general should have said to
them are you freaking out of your mind
this has got all kinds of constitutional
concerns you should not do it oh now the
constitution now he cares about the
constitution now he cares about people's
rights now i mean you know again this is
the guy who taught he could constantly
tweets about real america the guy
wouldn't know [ __ ] real america if he
watched it molest the student athlete
this piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
this piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] and i hope
that documentary absolutely slam dunks
him in the trash i hope there's criminal
charges on this piece of [ __ ] because he
obviously is sweating out guilt here
just profusely it is it's disgusting i
want to move on to um to what ann
coulter tweeted because uh it is it is
significant but while i'm doing that i
want to ask you gabe who's in your
twitter circle
have you seen this thing they've already
asked me like four times this morning do
you want to you want to do a circle jerk
that's what
literally twitter is
uh i don't have that feature yet
oh no actually wait no i do i do i do
yeah yeah twitter circle there isn't
anyone in your twitter circle yet when
you add people they'll show up here what
is the difference i don't know i don't
know
is it is it i guess is the idea people
won't be notified when they're out of
your circle how it works uh is it just
basically getting notification about
these people
well so oh
it's kind of like the community thing
but it's your own little personal i
don't know it's a circle jerk but you
can make a community private so i'm
saying
i thought about because they've asked me
like four times this morning i was like
well maybe gabe could be in my circle my
twitter circle jerk maybe i already send
you dms and talk no
well communication you should see the
images that this son of a [ __ ] spends
me
there are there are some crazy ones like
uh
when madison caught their video came out
and there were some other ones that you
sent me i'm like what in the actual
[ __ ] oh i remember what it was wasn't
there one where um matt gatz was
standing at the the foot of a bed or
something or there was some kind of
weird thing
that you sent me and i was like
i i question any time it says gabe
sanchez sent you an image i'm like
i don't know i don't know if i i
i within 24 hours of me sending texts i
pretty much just like black out
is that how that works yeah yeah here is
uh i went to the ann coulter thread ron
has a video of an ear this is um
i don't know what this is this is posted
uh recently and just just a few minutes
ago i don't know if this is recent or
this is like proving how racist she is
which is not hard to do with ann coulter
let's listen it's influencing i should
say influencing certain conservative
outlets on tv and radio is everybody
they hear from is one of the you know
die hard the few dwindling remaining
trump fanatics but
after the election and then after
january 6
normal people i'm not a normal person
i'm a political nut and i stopped paying
attention to politics it's just a drag
oh god you definitely aren't nut jesus
christ what i don't know what this is
about but uh ann coulter um obviously
and she's been off the trump train for a
long time because she's she saw this as
a sinking ship and she knew that she
didn't want to tie her ankle to this
[ __ ] um which is
which is
it's one of those things i feel like
within the republican like you're like
it's a catch-22 because of how deeply
rooted trump is you're [ __ ] if you are
associated with him and you're [ __ ] if
you aren't associated with him because
then you have people within the
republican party who say oh you're not
with trump then you are not with the
republican party you are a rhino right
and then you got people who are with
trump and you're like dude you're
[ __ ] crazy man you're a fascist like
well here she is this is this is the
video the clip trump's done the video
subscribers only she's she's pimping her
sub stack apparently she's not
yeah well i mean you know she's treating
it as a online i don't know i do you
think ann coulter has an only man's i
wouldn't i don't know just like audio
just audio of her talking with photos of
um but um she also tweeted something
this morning about uh white people yeah
[ __ ] white people are oppressed or
some [ __ ] you know because she's a she's
she's a nazi
um she doesn't claim to be one but she
definitely is now let's see where the
hell is it let me see if i can find this
tweet oh here it is let's see i got it
over here let me copy and paste over
here um ann coulter tweets
uh let's see she says she says here they
uh they won't do it meaning uh is any
republican in the country talking about
anti-white discrimination what the [ __ ]
they should be
should be because you know
that's who votes for them they won't do
it
you can show them that the white vote
determines the outcome of every election
and they will not mention white people
quote what can we do for asians the
spanish blacks voters whites [ __ ] off
what is she talking about this is the
furthest thing from the absolute truth
well it's what republican party does
good lord the republican party stands
around and says what can we do for a
asians hispanics and black voters are
you kidding me
that is that's what she get the [ __ ] out
of here with this nonsense
she is such a [ __ ] buffoon that's i
don't think
hear the the statement is wrong right
she's making the arguments like what can
we do for them oh i see right right but
really but really like well this is this
is for anyone who isn't uh isn't a
republican she's saying what do we do
for these people of color whites can go
[ __ ] themselves right
but you can flip this and say
republicans look at this statement and
say what can we do two asians two
hispanics right two black voters to get
white votes exactly votes and you see
that when they gerrymander they
redistrict they
you know make it illegal for people to
get [ __ ] water while they're waiting
in line to vote
to practice democracy
or just plain and simple take human
beings and put them on buses and humic
human trafficking them across the entire
country because they're brown
like literally just because they're
brown
it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] gross they're
[ __ ] gross republicans are [ __ ]
gross um there's a couple other whoa
wait a second lauren windsor has a new
video here new video what's that this is
what is what the [ __ ] is this
how was
the fbi this is since we've been on the
air um let's see lauren is great but
let's see how she uh gets ted cruz here
i wanted to say thank you so much for
all you're doing today
and i just think it's so important that
like you guys are actually did you find
all those irs agents
but i think it's a marriage
i think we need to fight to do that we
need to fight to have real oversight
great thank you so much
oh my god how in the hell don't they
have pictures of lauren like up in their
offices trying to figure out i'm curious
you know it's just like the amount of uh
you know puts glasses on changes her
hair wears something different you know
like i'm just like i guess they are not
able to be like oh [ __ ] we should not
talk to this person right right right i
mean you know even even with people like
uh
with um with walter right he's made
videos that have millions of views right
of him going to rallies and protests and
things like that making fun and trolling
right wing people
now i mean yeah there's a lot of people
in the u.s but i would imagine that
someone along the way would say oh wait
you're that dude that makes fun of us
so
i don't know well either they either
they're that dumb or what speaking oh
look at that he pulled right up on right
up on the phone look at that let's let's
listen to walter here so what are we
doing today student loans okay
joe biden is canceling
950 billion dollars in student loans
that's the wrong number what's what's
the real number
350 billion okay where did i get 950
billion oh that's the amount that uh big
businesses didn't have to pay back in
joe biden is cancelling
950 billion dollars and so oh i did it
again 350 950.
joe biden cancelled 900
it's funny because online he he was like
does anyone know because i was wondering
why he was asking the question on
twitter he asked does anyone know how
much
how many loans were forgiven
right and then now that i see the video
i'm like oh cool okay i put two two
together here and it's clearly because
of that that's what he was i mean which
is a valid point right we talked about
it
when we were when we were live streaming
the announcement that day we talked
about how the fact that these
republicans you know the hypocrisy again
within the republican party is so
[ __ ] rich
that they say we will not forgive the
loans of those people who are struggling
who are looking to advance their way of
life by looking into
uh
higher education getting a college
degree so they can get a job but on the
other end they're like oh yeah ppp loan
money take it forget it no problem
benny loco here um
really going after someone i don't know
she's going after someone in the chat or
who's on the video but here is here is
ronnie jackson he's also trending let's
see why he's trending what he said this
morning you know it's really funny how
he's like freaking out fox news and all
these trader tv news networks they're
all only showing the redacted parts of
the affidavit like that's the only part
it's not going to be unredacted yeah
there's a there's a fair amount of this
document that is unredacted well they
don't want their audience to see that
book right right well it's the same
thing like we'll show that we'll show
the cctv footage we'll we want to to
release the search warrant unredacted
you had it you had the inventory list of
items you could have released them if
you wanted however if you do it shows
that your narrative is false and that
you did in fact steal very very
important documents top secret
classified skiff documents from the
government and took them to mar-a-lago
and kept them in very unsecure locations
so if they show anything other than a
bunch of black bars then they look like
an idiot because it exposes for them as
the liar what what what what the
hilarious part about these black bars
and the [ __ ] that's redacted underneath
it is even worse than the [ __ ] that's
unredacted for trump right and them and
they're like oh look it's redacted
because they don't they don't want to
show that they're corrupt like no
they're also they're also making the
argument of like there's no reason that
you should even look at this redacted
document because look it's all black
bars and it's right and if someone were
to like oh that let's read the document
they would find some revealing stuff
right like what he had already
classified documents right exactly well
let's listen to ronnie jackson's
justification here let's listen does no
one trust the fbi the doj anymore i
don't trust them any further that i can
throw that entire building yeah when
you're being investigated by the
department of justice for overturning
the election i would say you probably
don't trust them anymore yeah that would
be my guess why did you need protection
from the oath keepers right right what
right what what
were you yeah what secured data did you
have on you that day where everyone
wants to know i wonder if that's
redacted let's listen and so this is
just their attempt to try to stave off
the special master who knows what they
got out of there i don't trust these
people at all they came in they spent
nine hours in there they walked in with
backpacks they kicked out
the president's lawyers the secret
service agents who knows in my opinion
i'm just gonna say if they told me that
they found something i wouldn't know
that they actually found it there or if
they just said they found it there i
don't trust this organization anymore
the american people don't trust this so
now they're now they're back to the
planted evidence gabe yeah that doesn't
make any sense because i want my planted
documents back it doesn't make any sense
tony because here's the thing
christina bob said i wasn't allowed to
watch it however the trump family
watched it happen live
right well and that is the reason why
that's the reason why the
fbi wanted the closed circuit television
turned off is so that they couldn't
watch them because they didn't want
trump to know
what they were taking and what they
weren't and the reason why is to you
know
get him a little you know
is undies in a bundle
right i mean
who knows maybe he'll i mean he's been
on true social [ __ ]
whining whining tonight
about the unfair treatment that he just
he received because he took classified
top secret documents from the government
and everyone's like why did you need
them and they'd be like yeah well he
shouldn't have had that but the
treatment by the doj was totally
unjustified
i'm pretty sure that if anyone else like
obama or someone else if someone took
their work home with them
and it was highly classified top secret
government documents right and they said
i'm just gonna take this home oh [ __ ]
yeah right no one would ever let you out
of the [ __ ] building or room
and if they did find out that you took
it
dude [ __ ] under the jail done there
is no reason why you would even have the
light of day shown or the ability to
even defend yourself and say well i was
just taking my homework i was taking my
work home with me because i'm i'm that
dedicated to the american people yeah my
ass [ __ ] yeah right well i mean here's
the thing here's one of the freak outs
this is from yesterday
this is
i mean i said i said in the first the a
block i said it seems like he's lost his
marbles but really the marbles packed
their [ __ ] and they [ __ ] left they're
like all right fred get your [ __ ]
we are out of this this guy has lost his
goddamn he's gone he's gone he's off the
rails here's what he says this is what
the former bret this is the former
president who lost by 8 million votes
he post on fraud social which is about
done anyways he says so now it comes out
conclusively
that the now this is on cap capital
letters and i'm not going to yell here
but fbi buried the hunter by laptop
story before the election which is not
true and that's not true that it's now
coming out that they buried the hunter
biden laptop story they're still
investigating the laptop apparently
knowing that if they didn't quote trump
would have easily won 2020 presidential
election this is really stupid so what
he's saying here
is that if everyone would have known
that the hunter biden lamp stop story
existed which we all knew it existed
because they couldn't stop [ __ ]
talking about it
and everyone had a [ __ ] copy on a
thumb drive right right like matt games
i want to answer this first off why do
you have the contents of his laptop and
second off
how are you going to prove
that the documents or evidence or photos
or whatever is on there i'm not saying
that they're not hunter biden but i'm
what i am bringing up is like
beyond the fact of you having this thumb
drive with the contents how do i know
that other things weren't put in there
like these emails
here's the main thing though he calls it
the hunter biden laptop story it's a
it's a great story grandpa it's a great
story but it's not evidence he goes on
to say this is a massive fraud and
election interference so it's now
election interference so he's admitting
that in in 2016
when james comey came out and gave press
conferences and sent letters that that
was all election and interference that
favored him is what he's admitting in
this statement here which is not true
but again he's he's projecting
at a level never seen before in our
country a level never seen before you
mean the fbi has never released
statements during an election year that
affected an election get the [ __ ] out of
here here's what he says remedy this is
the remedy this is this is the elixir
that he wants
for our country declare the rightful
winner
which i don't know who th who he's who
the [ __ ] he's talking to who is the
rightful the rightful like it's the same
language that jenny thomas
said oh we anointed him the rightful
it's like dude this isn't this isn't
yeah but who is gonna declin like is
this the same thing when he's waving his
hands over documents i don't know what
the [ __ ] he's talking about here like
there's no there is absolutely the
uh unfortunately or unfortunately in our
democracy there is no
[ __ ] thing that
triggers another election that that
doesn't happen yeah we have set
elections at certain times in our
country it's not like the parliament and
uk where they can actually they can
trigger an actual election
like they can just trigger it but that
that's not how it works in this country
to trigger an election there has to be
certain things that happen but just
because
captain big mac here gets his undies in
a bundle doesn't mean we have to
retrigger or declare a winner he goes on
to say or and
okay
this would be
the minimal solution declare the 2020
election
irreparably compromised and have a new
election immediately
yeah number one why does he capitalize
election
in this instance
tony it's just like one of those things
why didn't he do all caps on immediately
i feel like i feel like honestly if we
were gonna
fake this statement
i would have capitalized immediately
there a hundred percent you would think
that there would be an emphasis on
immediately right he loves to capitalize
election he i don't know a time when
i've read these statements or his or his
trump announcements that they don't
have election uh capitalized i don't
know it's like capitalized or in all
caps because he's got both in this right
right but typically election will be
capitalized e so i don't know
i don't know that's just how he does it
that's that's what he says and he
doesn't change the way i mean i
understand down here at the 2020
election because that's like a that's
like a name mm-hmm
but when he's just talking about an
election in jail like i said he's he's
giving he's giving the fbi and the doj
and ultimatum like he has any say in
this matter like he's like look guys
before this [ __ ] gets out of hand
because that's what he's doing right now
he is he is giving an ultimatum to say
either fix the [ __ ] problem
or you're gonna see a problem right he
is he is inciting people to say
either make me the president or redo the
election if anything happens from there
[ __ ] it
well i mean this is his but this is his
fear that if he's not the president he's
going to get indicted he's going to go
to prison right the other thing too that
i think is important that we have to
keep an eye on um because it's kind of a
laughable thing where he's been bragging
to people that he has classified
information about
the president mccrone's sex life or some
[ __ ]
um again this is the reason why this guy
was a danger from the very beginning not
when he left office in 2020 when the
[ __ ] came down the escalator and
he paid all those people to stand around
with signs that said they love trump and
he started to denigrate [ __ ] brown
people in this country that that is the
moment when this country should have
went ant that's not the something right
we're gonna do that's dangerous as [ __ ]
and we're seeing the ramifications of
that right now when the guy is freaking
out on fraud social
telling telling people if you don't make
me king i'll make myself king and
someone else will make me clean right i
don't understand or someone else will
make him queen i don't know no it could
happen it could happen everybody thanks
for joining us for two hours here on
tuesday
come back tomorrow same time same place
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch don't forget
to subscribe to the youtube channel you
can catch us every single day here on
youtube also we simulcast from the midas
touch facebook page every single weekday
follow us on twitter at tony michael's
pod you're not gonna miss a thing over
on the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends also if you missed the episodes
you can listen to them in your car in
your airpods wherever you are
taking a hike whatever you want to do
while you're over there subscribe to our
podcast on your favorite directory also
leave us a great review that helps us
out if you want to support pro-democracy
speech which you should be doing you can
do that for this show at
support.tonymichaelspod.com you can use
the qr code go to the tonymichaels.com
also see all the great merch there the
[ __ ] merch and the gabe sanchez merch
and we also have the doubt me shirts up
there on the merch store so don't forget
to go get your doubt me merch at
store.thetonymichaels.com
gabe until tomorrow same time same place
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking